[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
words
have no meaning identity is totally
self-generated and socially constructed
and our nation is nothing more than a
matter of narrative that can be changed
at a moment's notice this is what the
left has been telling us
increasingly for many years now
we are living in a culture that is
dominated at once
by science in the the religion of
secular science and also by whatever
sort of fantasies we want to construct
with which we can build our own reality
i've been trying to make sense of this
for a very long time and i i just can't
make heads or tails of it so fortunately
i have been able to call on the
expertise of one of our nation's
top scientists dr anthony rizzi who is
the director
of the institute for advanced physics
dr rizzi you may have heard his name he
gained worldwide recognition
by solving an 80 year old problem in
einstein's theory
i was really close to solving it so i he
got it before i did
so i'll have to give him credit there uh
holds degrees from mit
and princeton and is just just all
around one of our nation's top
scientists dr rizzi thank you so much
for being here
well thank you for having me it's good
to be here science
is the topic of the day of the decade
would seem to be in a way the kind of
faith of our culture now
and yet on the other hand we're told
that really nothing is real
and we can reinvent the whole world
simply by
saying that it is so uh can you help
walk me through this a little bit
because
i think that the left i'm i'm being kind
of silly with some of the points they're
making
but the left has been very persuasive
at convincing people that whatever they
want to do however irrational
however contradicted by the reality that
we all see with our own eyes
that that has the credibility of science
and therefore cannot be disputed
yeah it's really really a good summary
in a lot of ways that the the thing i
would add to it is that it's not just
the left it's the right it's all of us
that have adopted this kind of
um well it sounds good to me and um
by the way that uh you're not very
scientific
and so you you don't i don't have to
listen to you and
um so but that comes from uh
uh you know the both anytime there's an
evil in the world you have to look for a
good that's perverted you know if you
have a slug that's gone bad nobody
worries about that too much you know
because he can't do much
it's when you have like you know a
modern germany gone bad that's when you
were
you have a good a powerful thing gone
evil and so you have to look for a good
and that's good is the scientific method
was a great discovery around the 1600
most people don't realize they've never
really thought about
what the scientific method is and what
it is
fundamentally and you you can get this
at our website iapweb.org where i have a
bunch of material we have a bunch of
material on this
but the point is is that it what is it
it's any at the
core it's an equation so when a
scientist talks to you he really has an
equation in the back of his head that he
doesn't know how to quite get out
and so that equation becomes for him and
then therefore the world
a kind of symbol replacing reality
and that transmits to everybody that
doesn't understand that people don't
understand an equation so they transmit
it as i get to make up the world as i
want
and so there is no attempt really to
study and learn
from the world in the slow way that it's
necessary there's just
like well okay it kind of works so and
and kind of works can mean something
really awful as long as you get an
output that the
larger culture likes and so you get a
really construct construct-based kind of
reality like if it kind of makes sense
if i come up to you and i try to
question you
then um you say something back to me and
i go wow okay that doesn't really work
with my system and i just tweak my
system i don't fundamentally say well
let me rethink this all i just tweak it
and
try to add what you put in and i never
really fundamentally change
and i keep marching down this road you
know over the last 60 years it's been
really clear that we shifted from where
we used to be
to where we are if you took a person
from 1965 and beamed him forward
he would be shocked he'd probably have a
heart attack what is this america
it's just the place that you know
already that people talked about when
they came back from vietnam the guys
that came back from vietnam
you know they're in prison camps for
five years or something and they were
shocked
this isn't the america that i was
fighting for
so this is this powerful shift that you
know modernity is defined by this
as you say it's science it's what the
but most people have been sort of left
out of the scientific advance
and they sort of take the sort of fumes
that come from
the science and then they they justify
almost anything they want to justify
even though
you know that you want to say it but i
flunked that physics stuff in fact
sometimes i'm fr proud that i flunk that
physics stuff
but yet i'm using that physics stuff to
justify it's
just right so you wouldn't believe it
unless you
you know unless you see it unless you
see with your eyes and then you'll be
told to deny it
i want to get into this this word that
you've used repeatedly
that i am told doesn't even exist namely
reality
because for for a long time and and i
i think your point is excellent that a
lot of people on the right have fallen
into this trap
too we have taken the abstract dialogue
that we we all seem to have
as evidence that there's no connection
between the abstractions and the real
world so for instance
i'm catholic uh so that's my set of
values
but someone else maybe is muslim maybe
someone else is
an atheist and you know that's their
values and we can never
discuss or investigate whether
one of those sets of values has has any
more uh truth to it
than any other set of values the same
could be said of my
identity as a a man you know maybe my
identity could be different than that
same could be said for the history of
our country
you see now especially with the the 1619
project
what the authors of that that project
set out to do in their own words was to
reframe american history as though
the reality of it had nothing to do with
the question it was
all just about the narrative so if
as it seems to me you are disputing this
view of the world
how do we recover a reality based
understanding of our politics so i mean
it's really strange to first hear you
have to go learn some very basic physics
because physics is the first science
and nobody's saying that because you
know well like i say we're all kind of a
little bit like scared to go back to
that time where we had a very bad
physics teacher and he told us some
stuff we had no idea what he was talking
about wrote some equation
but it's simpler than that you know the
founding fathers of this country bring
bring up the 1690 project they they
weren't trying to form a new economic
system
they were really radically doing
something that nobody had ever done
before
the first time that i'm aware of in
human history that you had a principle
based country
one that wasn't based simply on well we
happened to be in this land area on this
island let's call ourselves a country
well we happen to have the same skin
color we happen to have the same this or
that random thing
no this was a principle based country
you know made chesterton say
america is a funny country it has the
soul of a church
meaning i think what he meant by that is
a principle based country so you can be
in hawaii which is not disconnected at
all and you're just as much as an
american as someone in
kansas city and um
so that principle base is what they
where did they get it from they got it
from the basic understanding of nature
which which is what the word physics you
know
aristotle coined the word it just means
nature
but looking at the world around you what
you see and they built from that and so
that's why you know for example to the
man
every single founding father didn't
believe in the existence of god they
thought you could know it
they knew the existence of god so nobody
doubted it
and so that's the firm foundation as you
see the world you see
by you know there's a book that i
recommend that people get to start this
process that's called the kids
introduction to physics and beyond
which takes you from the physical world
to god and it's very
it's not just for kids because it's for
all of us missing this sort of
connection to the ground up
and that takes you and so that's the
firm position that they had
look this is what americans do they see
evil they attack it
and so that's what they did the first
americans really set this tone
look injustice needs to be stopped
and so you know we want to make friends
with the king and that most people don't
realize initially the american
founders were like hoping that they'd
scare them and they'd say okay we'll be
fair again
but they wouldn't and so they were
forced into a revolution but they wanted
a positive vision it wasn't just simply
negative
they wanted this positive vision that
each of us has this high dignity
with innate rights that come from our
nature that in turn comes from god that
and the gods you could know
exists and that so you could make
conclusions
as opposed to as you just said well let
me pick i'll pick this religion i kind
of like the flavor of that religion you
know there's 32 flavors and that flavor
is the best one for me
and no matter what anybody says i like
that flavor you know
um you know that we even say it you know
i don't care what i don't care what you
say
that's that's my flavor so i i have to
pause here because what you've just said
is so
radical and i happen to know that it was
once common sense but
it certainly is is today i think
considered an absolute heresy
what you are saying is that from the
physical world
we can know things about the
metaphysical world so from
the physical objects all around us using
using our reason
we can know things about god we can know
things about the world that is
immaterial
and we can also know things about how we
ought to live together how we ought to
have a government how we ought to pursue
justice
you have just contradicted i think every
single principle
of modern society how dare you sir
yes i really have because i've went
i've done two things one is i've went to
a principled core
and starting point whereas you're not
supposed to do that your sis will start
where you kind of like and i'll say you
know michael i kind of like this and
then you tell me what you kind of like
you're not supposed and by going to the
core that already violates everything
right
but then number two i actually point out
that you can know things from that
with certainty that you know that
therefore you can't teach the contrary
of for example in schools
because you know i mean we're starting
to get to the point where we can't teach
math anymore and a colleague of mine at
princeton did a nice job of
debunking that but i'm afraid to say you
know that
you i'm sure you're aware that the new
uh what is that the um
the uh oregon uh department of education
has decided that
math is unfair because there's multiple
answers well that's not what happens
when you look at the physical world
there's
you know there's one uh answer um to
two plus two equals four and that's the
one i just gave
and so you have to really so so so the
point though that
is you look at the physical world and
you physics comes before metaphysics
because it's only by looking at the
physical world that there's you see that
there's a metaphysic
something what aristotle called
metaphysics something beyond
meta means beyond for the physical you
see that the physical world
in me by its contingency immediately
shows you
some existence so dr rizzi what you mean
by that
because i think a lot of people are
going to hear what you just said and say
well i don't know i can see you know i
can see him see michael's leftist tears
tumbler
it does not necessarily follow from the
existence of his tumblr
that god exists or that there's
something metaphysical out there so how
am i supposed to know this how is uncle
aristotle supposed to
prove to me that that's true so so so
you know really the thing i need to say
is we have to
this like if somebody came to me and
said you know tell me how to
uh how to solve a differential equation
you know i'd have to talk walk them from
the beginning
right right so there's some steps there
it's not hard that's why i sent them to
the kids introduction to physics
because you're going to have to take
some time to see it the same way you
didn't
we're not used to these things being
complex
and we we leave so the reason morality
seems sort of random is because we don't
spend any time thinking about how you
get from the bottom to the top
right right in the same way that the the
reason that uh higher mathematics and
for me higher mathematics
means anything more advanced than
algebra but the reason it seems kind of
random is just because
i don't spend any time thinking about it
so i don't have a meth methodical way of
thinking about it
right and the difference though between
and that's a great point because it's a
great comparison
and the reason that it feels so to you
for morality and everybody else is
because unlike
math people spend no time on i mean
intellectuals spend very little time
trying to go from the beginning to the
end
so that doesn't get transmitted to the
culture and whereas
where there's a lot of time i can tell
you spent on math and physics
i mean yeah it takes took me it takes
the average physicist 17 years after
high school to become a physicist
so that shows you the depth of
understanding that we have yeah and
that can transmit you know in some way
to wow there's something really
important there you see things like you
know this
cell phone and stuff that proves whereas
you see very evident little evidence
that anybody's been trained morally to
think morally
and so they you don't see the actions
and so you don't think there's anything
there but it
if you imagine that math is very is very
simple relative to
uh human nature you can see that because
math has to do with counting parts of
stuff
yeah well i have parts here but i'm much
deeper than a bunch of parts
so if that's that complicated as you
just said to get to something beyond
algebra is that complicated imagine how
complicated it is to understand
human nature right of course and you
can't expect it just
you can't you can't expect to just say
like okay here's the answer to
the derivative of the elliptical
integral you know
any more than you can say here's why in
two seconds here's why you shouldn't
punch your neighbor in the face you're
right right
well i love that point i mean on on the
complexity of it all
and i obviously agree with the point
you're making which is so heterodox
today
that you can look at the natural world
and derive
metaphysical conclusions from it so
let's say that we grant all of that
we direct people to read these
introductory books
we direct people to read say saint
thomas aquinas for instance
who who baptizes aristotle it is said
one of the
most intelligent people to ever walk the
earth every crazy blue-haired college
student today
thinks that she is much smarter than
thomas aquinas but i promise she is not
and let's say that that i can therefore
conclude okay my tumblr is
contingent it did not cause itself
uh it is better than some things worse
than other things and and
by ways of argumentation i can get from
that arguments from perfection
contingency cause
other arguments i can get all the way up
to god okay i see it i agree that's why
i go to church on sunday
but why is it the case dr rizzi that it
seems to me some of the greatest
offenders
against this reason and some of the
greatest
promoters of this shallow scientism seem
to be these
very well educated very intelligent
scientists themselves
well so so that has to do with that the
core you know physics is the first
science
because everything we know comes through
what we know through the senses and
physic
physics is just a study of the physical
world so it shows that us physicists
have done a poor job
showing the primacy of our field number
one but it shows we've
done a very poor job of getting people
to be interested in it
and to see that it affects everything
and but but the fact
is is because we focus on an equation so
if you ask you know if most people
know e equals m c squared right but what
does that mean is that
i don't see an e equals m c squared
inside here right
right you know where is that e i you
know
and the point is is that as a physicist
i have not been trained to spend time
asking what
you know not just why but what is this
and so instead i have equations in my
head so when i'm trying to talk to you i
kind of have to in
oh and when i'm talking to myself and
trying to relate this equation to an
experiment i kind of have to invent a
story
to connect it it's what in humanities
departments which
where where this stuff bleeds to next
and gets much worse
they call an account let's make an
account what's your account
and i'll tell you my account and then
the account just sort of morphs without
anything to
you know to contain it or to to connect
it to reality
only only some practical output which
increasingly just becomes do i haven't
you know do i fit into the cleat do i
have power
and and it just leaves you but but i
have to say that most physicists are
very shy about
this they kind of know that they don't
know anything unlike the humanities
people that
should know they don't know anything the
physicist kind of does so most
physicists are pretty shy about talking
about
you know and they'll say things like
well that's not interesting to me and
what they mean by that is i have no idea
how to think about it
so you know so it that's the truth of
the matter there's only a few physicists
and people grab on to them that will
talk in public because they kind of know
that well i don't really know how to
step out and so what that does is you
get stuck in the equation
you go well i don't know how to talk
about that i don't know what to do about
that so you dive
more deeply in the equation and that
breaks the bond
and that's what's happening to america
it's breaking the bond between nature
and your understanding of her and so as
that
progress moves america which is deeply
ingrained in nature deeply planted in
nature gets more and more
broken from nature and it becomes harder
and harder for anybody within that
culture to explain
what is the true nature of that's why i
wrote this article as you know what is
america
to kind of tell people what it is it's
the first principle-based country in
history one that defines
herself by the principle not by a land
mass or
skin color or something trivial you know
la
um but by a principle that says there's
a human nature
and from that human nature certainly in
alienal right spring because of the
nature made
made but made by god
that has certain constraints because
in certain direction because of that
nature it has a certain
ordination which is an ordination to
grow in knowledge and truth
and virtue i mean this is the founding
fathers so i send people to what is my
what is america article to get them to
see
to get re-inspired by these great men
washington for example was at pains to
to make sure that his
troops were virtuous were growing in
virtue
you know and he he says this he tries to
get them
you know to use civil language and to
use to not
um do things that are untoward and and
he realizes this is what
is going to make not just the army win
but the wake make winning worthwhile
and that's universal character of all
the founders of wanting to
build in virtue and wanted to be
robustly connected with what's real and
what's
true well on this question of what
what our founding fathers were really
like what
our country is really all about i have
been reliably informed
dr rizzi given my long experience
of education you know k through 12 and
all the way up through college
i've been told that our founding fathers
were
deists who founded a secular country
where there was a firm separation
between church and state
founded on the principles of liberty
which means being able to do whatever
you desire or follow whatever appetites
you have so
it would seem to me that you are telling
me that everything i've been taught
is completely wrong could you maybe
briefly take us through how that how
that's the case
yeah i mean that that very briefly
yeah i i'd say essentially you know
you're right in some areas we've been
told some right things but essentially
at the core
you're right we've been given a bad
physics of physics
and understanding the physical world
that is
confused and even wrong in certain in
severe places
that then leads us to these conclusions
that
you know that just aren't true that the
the founding fathers
like i said earlier you know what but
you have to make a distinction between
revelation
and natural understanding of the world
and to the man
all of them were on the page and most of
them
uh you know by the way in my book the
science before science i go through this
in another higher level fashion where i
explain
that you can prove the immortality of
the human
soul and they knew that pretty much to
the man
they knew that it's not as complete as
it was for god but pretty much and they
knew that there was an
external goal to life and they acted on
that and they all worried about it you
know the
in the in these days of people thinking
that america is racist you know
you can go to the jefferson memorial and
on that
plaque it just it's there i mean you can
say stuff about jefferson fell short
this
this or there but up there we put for
ourselves
this jefferson quote that says you know
i fear for my nation because there is a
just
god and slavery is a horrible monstrous
thing i'm paraphrasing
so you know who puts that up there
unless this is a calling to something
higher
and jefferson actually said this these
are people that are worried about
the direction they have a direction
that's a higher direction and americans
have consistently
manifested this you see them you know so
many people think americans are and the
europeans thought this um that americans
were like
after money alone or commerce alone
and all you have to do is look at world
war ii right where all these things that
were supposedly dedicated to commerce
alone
became dirt poor in order to defeat in
franklin's word
the mortal enemy of our christian
religion
not to make more money but to stop the
evil that was happening in germany
right um you know and they literally you
know
sacrificed you know basic commodities
in order to do this and so that kind of
shoots down one of the you know the
things were individualistic you know you
don't band together like that if you're
just
okay well joe you're it's up to you doc
you know die or live yourself
right right um this wasn't just joe next
door this is the guy across
the sea and so this is a
radical um lie that we're told that we
all tell it to ourselves we all believe
in ourselves you know we have to undo
that and really come back to what's the
reality around us
and see that we claim these
um deep principled um
lives that the founders wanted us to
have and and scotched in
in the country you know it seems to me
what
we're describing is is going on today
is this exaltation of diversity
and subjective feeling or preference
as these paramount virtues and what
we're seeing from the founding fathers
and all the great men who built our
civilization
is instead a reliance on
unity a call for unity and a reliance on
objective reality and reason and our
ability to know things about the world
the physical world and
and the metaphysical world too and those
two visions
are completely at odds they're they are
diametrically opposed
but then what do you say to someone who
shows up maybe with blue hair i don't
know i'm just
creating an image here who says to you
well yeah dr rizzi okay
jefferson you think he did some good
things and but i know he did some bad
things too and so you like him that's
your preference and i
i don't like him and that's my
preference and so so why is your
narrative
about the country any better
than my narrative about the country yeah
so
um that's a really good question and
then the point goes back is a complex
thing right like if somebody asked me
how do you prove this this derivative is
equal to this i have to send you back to
the beginning and i have to send you
back to the material that i talked about
i suggest that i suggest to this person
you start with the what is america
article
and then let that lead you to the kids
introduction to physics and the science
before science
and the other material that we have to
kind of start digesting
how you prove things because when you
know something as opposed to believe
something you prove it
you don't just say it you prove it you
don't just have enough
army of people to enforce it on people
yeah you prove it and right that's what
the first amendment of the constitution
was really about and it's clear that it
was about because they were
you know there was pamphlets circulating
they weren't trying to force things on
people they were trying to convince
people yeah and the declaration itself
says that for the for a d i
i'm going to paraphrase decent men want
to give reasons
for their disagreement and not just to
say
so you know we've deluded this word
argument
to mean i yell at you i call you a few
names you call me a few names back
and whoever you know the audience thinks
wins but enough
jeers and cheers then wins you know but
that's not the founder's view it's not
a sane view it's not western culture
view that it's always been you have
people like as you mentioned saint
thomas aquinas
whose book reads more like a modern day
math book than it does anything else in
our culture
he asks a question and he gives a series
of
rebuttals to his own question and then
answers them in
in and he goes has a proof back to the
physics in his answers
but but dr rizzi i i have been told rel
i've been reliably informed by the very
same people who told me all those things
about the country and the founding
fathers
i have been reliably informed that
science is opposed
to religion that science and reason and
all the our wonderful modern brain and
mind
is opposed to religion we've only got a
couple minutes left but
surely surely you have to grant their
point on that don't you
no no i mean i don't because what you
just said what we just said is that
the founding fathers are lived examples
of it you see the world
and from that you see that god exists
and if
and that's what most people mean by
religion that there is a god and what
the founders knew and that's why
thanksgiving was proclaimed by both
jefferson
and washington that we owe a duty to him
to god that's what people mean by
religion and you can prove that
and so and science is about looking at
the world and
understanding what you can understand
about it the problem is that
we've let it become just simply an
equation in the minds of
of the smartest people in our culture
and been content not to know anything
about it ourselves
right and and so then we can then the
humanities people who don't have this
kind of
education rigorous education can then
tell you
things like that they're separate you
know and in fact they're right as long
as
it's an equation that sits in never
never land then it's about not only not
religion it's not about
anything that human doesn't give human
answers even to what something is
yeah right so as long as it's that way
then they're right when something when
you have a sciencey a science that
doesn't really
answer what then not only religion but
your humanity and everything else is
left out
and you can say that but that's only an
ignorance that doesn't understand that
scientists themselves want that equation
desire that equation to say something
real you know this this phrase uh trust
the scientists has been a very abused
phrase in our culture
but i would recommend that people trust
this scientist in particular
and especially so because you can use
your own powers of reason
to follow along in these arguments i
highly recommend that you
you follow uh dr anthony rizzi's work
uh dr rizzi where can people find you
so you can find me at iepweb.org you
just go there and then there's a link to
like
this america podcast we're going to be
doing a podcast in america here in a
couple weeks so
people will join for that and just click
around there and there's a phone number
and anything else you'd want to find
there
iapweb.org head on over i
i certainly look forward to hearing more
and reading more dr rizzi thank you for
being with us and clearing up all those
misconceptions
that i have accumulated over the years
thank you
[Music]
[Music]